- Well you got a new single,
with Florida Georgia Line,
so how did this come about?
'Cause you have a
friendship with them, right?
- Yeah of course, um, well um,
me and the boys, we
met actually doing the,
when I was asked to do
the remix of their first
single that I knew of, "Cruise".
And fortunately enough,
I did it, and you know,
we kinda made history coming
together with "Cruise" and,
and we bonded, right
off the gate with that,
with the video, we did
like two tours together,
and they're family now, man,
and you know, we've been
together ever since,
as far as communicating
and keeping in contact.
So when I started working on this project,
we came up with this idea, man,
and it was, it was
pretty special, you know.
We hammered it out, and I
wanted it to be my first single
off of my EP, "Heartland",
coming out top of next year.
- [Kelly] That's so awesome.
- Thank you.
- And honestly, I mean, even
I've gotten into country,
but I remember the first
person that I remember
crossing over into country,
doing something like that,
was you, and Tim McGraw,
Like way back in the day.
- Yeah.
- Like that's what,
so it's so funny that a lot
of people are doing it now,
but you were kinda the
pioneer of that, I feel like,
way back in the day.
- Yeah, you know,
the thing about it is like,
so, my uncle was the one
that got me into music,
and he was a huge Lionel Richie fan.
- [Kelly] Ooh.
- And Lionel used to do a lot of writing,
and he wrote for Kenny Rogers,
and he wrote for a lot
of different people.
And, my uncle would play
anything by Lionel Richie.
If it was sung, written,
produced, whatever,
he would play it.
And he used to play Kenny Rogers a lot,
and I, that was kinda
like how my love affair
for country music kinda started.
And it's one of the purest art forms
that still exists to this day.
But, I mean, you know--
- I feel like it's cousins with R&B.
Like growing up,
- [Nelly] Oh totally, totally.
I would listen to Trisha
Yearwood and like, Reba,
but also Toni Braxton,
- [Nelly] You nailed it.
- And like Monica and Brandy.
I feel like--
- [Nelly] You nailed it.
- It's the storytelling.
- And even if you listen to it,
a lot of the songs that are
traditional, huge R&B hits,
have also been transformed
into country music.
- Remember, like "I Swear",
cross over into both.
- [Nelly] "I Swear", yep.
- Yeah, there was um,
- He did uh, "Lady",
"Lady", Lionel Richie,
and Commodores did it.
But then him and Kenny Rogers did it.
So "I Will Always Love You",
Whitney Houston did it,
- Yeah.
- Kinda crossed it back over from Dolly's.
- That's 'cause it's all storytelling--
- From Dolly Parton, so yeah,
just the love, the passion,
and the honesty in the music
I think, it resonates with me.
- Me too, me as well.